[Música]
segundo bloque económico en directo
américa ya está conmigo nuevamente en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
nuevamente vamos a comenzar hablando de
china donde hay efectos financieros
debido a la crisis de evergrande así es
ahí el crédito se desaceleró en
septiembre debido al gigante
inmobiliario y su millonaria deuda como
recordarán la compañía no tiene dinero
para cumplir una deuda que asciende a
305 mil millones de dólares lo que hace
unas semanas provocó nerviosismo en los
mercados financieros aunque los nuevos
préstamos bancarios en china se
aceleraron en septiembre con respecto al
mes anterior no alcanzaron las
expectativas las instituciones
financieras ofrecieron unos 66 billones
de yuanes en nuevos préstamos en
septiembre cuando se estimaban que
serían colocados 181 la crisis de ever
run llegó a las grandes primas de riesgo
del mercado de deuda de las firmas
chinas más débiles a un máximo histórico
este miércoles y desencadenó una nueva
ronda de rebajas de calificación
crediticia los diferenciales de grado de
inversión también aumentaron su nivel
más bajo su nivel más amplio perdón en
más de dos meses el lunes
no pago casi 150 millones de dólares en
cupones de tres bonos luego de otros dos
incumplimientos en septiembre el fondo
monetario internacional aseguró que
china tiene las herramientas para
intervenir si la crisis del endeudado
gigante inmobiliario de bérgamo se
agravan según un informe del organismo
ya medio de la mala noticia a jorge en
el primer bloque de economía hay
problemas en las entregas del nuevo
iphone 3 porque así es y bueno creo que
vas a tener que esperar un poco más tu
pedido del nuevo iphone3g a paul podría
reducir sus objetivos de producción para
su nuevo modelo afectados por la escasez
de chips que también está afectando
otras industrias como la automotriz
según fuentes vinculadas a la compañía a
paul espera va a producir 90 millones de
nuevo modelo los últimos 3 meses de este
año pero ya bajo las previsiones y
luchan para entregar los pedidos
actuales al menos 10 millones de
unidades se dejarían de producir por
esta problemática a paul es uno de los
mayores compradores de chips en el mundo
pero ahora enfrenta las interrupciones
de suministro de otras industrias las
principales fabricantes de chips llevan
meses advirtiendo que no podrán cubrir
la demanda de al menos a mediados hasta
el próximo año el iphone 13 pro y el
iphone 13 promax salieron a la venta en
septiembre pero hay pedidos como los
estudios raúl que serán enviados hasta
dentro de un mes por los problemas de
producción pese a ello se espera que el
último trimestre del año la compañía
genere ventas por 120 mil millones de
dólares en ingresos esto representaría
un 7% más que el año anterior
bueno ahora vamos a hablar de otro tema
la reapertura las fronteras terrestres
de eeuu en términos económicos que
podemos esperar bueno esta reapertura
está programada para el próximo mes y
terminaría con un cierre de 19 meses
debido a la pandemia aunque hay algunas
restricciones que permitirán que los
ciudadanos extranjeros completamente
vacunados ingresen a los eeuu
independientemente del motivo del viaje
a partir de principios de noviembre esta
medida irá de la mano con una
flexibilización similar para los viajes
aéreos en ese país méxico y canadá
insistieron eeuu durante meses para que
levantara las restricciones de viaje
estas nuevas reglas sólo aplican a la
entrada legal a los eeuu este año entró
en vigencia el tratado o méxico estados
unidos y canadá conocido como teme que
tan sola en el 2019 raúl el intercambio
comercial de ambos países de méxico y
canadá fue de 44.000 millones de dólares
mientras que el de méxico y eeuu en el
mismo período fue de 614 mil 500
millones de dólares jorge vamos ahora a
hablar de los indicadores le pregunto
cómo abre wall suite pero wall street
abre con un leve alza pese a los datos
de la inflación que opacó la ganancia
desesperada de los inversores se espera
que operen mixto durante este miércoles
en asia los mercados cerraron mixtos
luego de los datos presentados por el
banco de china sobre el crédito ahí y en
europa las bolsas operan mixtas debido a
que los inversores temen que el alza de
los precios de las materias primas
impida la recuperación de las ganancias
corporativas pues mejores gracias por
este segundo y último bloque de economía
en directo américa nos vemos mañana con
más información vamos a orar directo
hasta parís
[Música]